Google “death” and this is what you’ll
get as one of the first images.
The figure is so ingrained in our culture
it's hard to separate death from, well Death.
This iconic image of death personified is
a skeleton that wields a scythe, and is named
the “Grim” Reaper.
But why?
To answer these questions we have to look
at ancient religion and artwork, Aramaic scripture,
and yes, the Black Plague.
How we conceptualize death, and how we choose
to personify it changes over time.
And there’s more to the Grim Reaper than
just doom and gloom.
[Monstrum intro.]
Macabre images of Death personified have been
around since at least the late 13th Century.
This illustration, “The Legend of the Three
Living and Three Dead,” is often considered
to be the first known European image of an
animated, skeletal death figure.
It’s based on a popular story from the second
half of the thirteenth century.
And I mean a very popular story, with versions
in French, English, Italian, and German.
The story goes that three finely dressed young
men, aristocrats or sometimes kings, are out
hunting when they come across three animated
corpses all in varying stages of decay.
To their horror, they recognize them as their
own ancestors, or perhaps even the men themselves.
The corpses warn the living trio of the fleetingness
of life, the grossness of death, and the need
for repentance – turning the men toward
a more righteous path.
The frescoes of the Camposanto in Pisa, a
part of the Piazza del Duomo known as the
“monumental cemetery” or “holy field”
were also inspired by this story.
The frescos portray a flying “Death” with
bat wings holding a scythe.
That same century an event of global proportions
fundamentally changed humanity’s relationship
with and perception of death—the bubonic
plague, or what we now commonly call the Black
Death.
Its monumental spread in the mid-14th century
in Europe, Asia, and Africa killed a huge
portion of the global population.
How did we even attempt to manage the horror
of such widespread death?
To give us more insight into the Black Death,
here’s Caitlin Doughty of Ask a Mortician.
So Caitlin, what do we know about how people
processed death during the bubonic plague?
Hi Emily, hi everyone.
So, let’s understand that by the end of
the 14th century, anywhere from 20%, which
is already a huge percentage, to 75% of the
global population had succumbed to the bubonic
plague.
And yes that’s quite a range but there was
inconsistent, inaccurate record keeping and
no reliable census or data collection.
But, any way you slice it— just a monumental
amount of death, causing economic, psychosocial,
and cultural effects on the population.
Turning Death into a humanoid figure— Death,
why he’s just like us!— may have been
a way to help us cope.
As the plague continued to rage on, skeletons
and even half decomposed corpses, became a
common visual trope.
They emphasized the universality of death
and served as a reminder of death.
“As I am so you too will be, folks!”
“The Three Living and the Three Dead”
story, which I love, was just the beginning.
Churches and cemeteries across Europe featured
allegorical scenes of the Danse Macabre—showing
skeletons, corpses, and living people from
all backgrounds, all walks of life interacting
together.
King or pauper, no one was safe from the plague.
Money and status can’t save you!
We also see the emergence of a singular Death
standing over bodies or collecting the dead,
“Triumph of Death” motifs, that illustrate
the huge numbers of dead the grave could consume.
This period also marks the appearance of artistic
renderings of these skeletons with weapons—a
bow, sword, sickle, or scythe.
For example, in the mid 14th century, the
poet Petrarch, wrote his poem Triumphus Mortis:
Trionfo della Morte (Triumph of Death) after
viewing the Camposanto frescos.
The text’s popularity [Petrarch’s Triumph
of death] inspired more illustrations and
paintings depicting Death as a skeleton or
a corpse standing on a cart riding over a
dying population, with a large scythe over
her shoulder.
That’s right, her shoulder.
Death’s gender can be either male or female
depending on the country and time period...
Those of us in the Slavic and Germanic-language
groups more often imagine a male Grim Reaper,
while a female version has been more dominant
in Romance and Latinate languages.
Don’t forget that much of European culture
harkens back to the same Greco-Roman roots.
Thus, male “death” gods in Greek and Roman
culture deeply influenced the Grim Reaper’s
appearance.
Thanatos [θænətɒs] the winged Greek
personification of nonviolent death, has been
compared to the Grim Reaper but there are
two main differences—Thanatos is always
male and he carries away the dead.
The Grim Reaper is more often conceptualized
as forcefully claiming the deceased, cutting
down lives indiscriminately.
There’s [Chronos/Χρόνος], Heronos
the male Greek god of time.
Who is often confused with Kronos [ˈkroʊnɒs
or Κρόνος] the ancient Greek god connected
to agriculture portrayed as an old man with
a beard, sickle in hand.
The physical resemblance of these three gods
and the natural associations with harvest,
the passing of seasons, and time aligned them
with death and each other.
When Renaissance artists and authors were
looking for ways to depict death, they adopted
elements from Thanatos, Heronos, and Kronos—and
replaced the hand-held sickle with the larger,
more efficient scythe.
Just butting in here for some scythe facts.
During this same time in the early 14th century
when we see this increase in imagery of Death
as a skeleton in art and literature, the long-handled
scythe that you can use standing up, was gaining
popularity in the corn harvests of medieval
Europe.
Scythes went viral in the corn harvesting
scene.
It was a faster way of mowing than the sickle,
the increased productivity meant fewer laborers
were needed.
But because of the strength and height needed
to use this larger tool, it was perceived
as a masculine object.
Those who wielded sickles in the fields were
called reapers.
Those who used scythes were “mowers.”
So, the Grim Reaper should technically be
the Grim Mower.
Which just doesn’t have the same ring to
it.
Up to this point in Medieval history, there
are clear associations of Death with time
and the harvest which helps explain why this
Grim Reaper, this figure representing Death,
is portrayed with scythe in hand “mowing
down” the living quickly and in great numbers—
much like the Black Plague.
Personifications of Death continued to be
popular reminding the living of the inevitability
of their end.
But Death was also a symbol of compassion—waiting
with open arms in the afterlife, a sign of
comfort and acceptance.
From this came association of Death with love,
leading to its portrayal as a bridegroom of
young Maidens during the Renaissance period.
And eventually, as the eroticized “demon
lover” which gained popularity in the 18th
and 19th centuries.
So how did Death come to be named the Grim
Reaper?
That actually didn’t happen until hundreds
of years after the Black Death.
The word “grim” has been in use since
the late 10th century to mean something “fierce,
cruel, savage or harsh in disposition or action;”
or “fiercely angry.”
The moniker “The Grim Reaper'' in reference
to the personification of Death first appears
in English literature in 1847 in The Circle
of Human Life, a partial translation of an
earlier German devotional text (Stunden Christlicher
Andacht) from 1841 that tracks the life of
a Christian.
So there you have it.
Death as a figure that takes lives with a
scythe has been around for a long time, but
the name Grim Reaper is more modern.
And since the 19th century, it's stuck.
The Grim Reaper pops up everywhere in popular
culture.
The interpretation can be more lighthearted
like in Death Takes a Holiday from 1934, Meet
Joe Black from 1998, or the TV show Dead Like
Me.
The Reaper here is meant to humanize Death
and show that they have motivations and physical
forms much like humans.
[opening credits Dead Like Me].
And it makes sense that in times of mass death,
we know a little something about that right
now, it helps to see Death as not some terrifying,
invisible, indiscriminate force bearing down
on us, but something with a face, maybe even
a personality.
Better that Death is like a bureaucratically
focused DMV worker, annoying but relatable,
than a black hole of nothingness.
It’s easy to see why that would make us
less anxious, and I’m fascinated to see
how art and literature personify death as
we continue to fight, and hopefully recover
from, the pandemic.
Like Caitlin said, more relatable interpretations
of the Grim Reaper in the 20th and 21st centuries
lessened the blow of his scythe so to speak
[Bill and Ted’s Excellent adventure clip],
but whenever there is a large loss of life
in the real world, Death returns to its allegorical
role as something to be feared.
Like in 1987, when Australia used the cloaked
figure to raise awareness about AIDS.
Or more recently in 2020, when political cartoonists
(and one Florida lawyer) used the Grim Reaper
to emphasize the dangers of COVID-19.
Around the world people evoked the dramatic
figure to emphasize high death tolls by the
global pandemic or as a warning of what might
meet someone who fails to recognize the significant
dangers of the virus.
Death is both personal and collective.
After all, Death is universal.